-I really want to just like get down quickly and get loot.
-If you want to do that, then we should go to a really
isolated place far away. That way no one else -
-get in a car and driving. Yeah. Oh, yeah, hell yeah.
I'll find us a car while you guys to get all the loot, okay
Flush Factory would that be out of the way enough?? I think people are gonna
Go to that. We should probably try um
I bet no one's really gonna go to Anarchy Akers (ANARCHY!). You'd go there alright. Let's do it alright
Like ten people just jumped towards anarchy akers
oh shit. ..yeah, they did should we change our trajectory?
No, I'm gonna. Just do it over here. Let's do it. It's do or die! I love the way
You go through the sky try and stick together and land so we could fight as a uh unit. you got it, okay
I'm going right for the middle. I think the middle like where the Red Barn is alright
You get that red barn with the red ouT terrier
the right of us
Yeah, they're going
They're gonna land northeast. I'm going for the the the main building any luck fell into the building
I found a med pack is that good? there's a
Submachine gun. No chest in here. I got a chest and an assault rifle good bit of
ammo
Okay, I heard oh, that's Wade (-_-). Oh, you got the oh okay my fucking area found a shield as well
Yeah, I'm doing pretty good. ooh! I got a blue something. I found there's two allies
Coming in the same building alright. I've got good guns and a sniper, okay
I've got a sub-machine gun and an assault rifle. I got a good combat shotty and an assault rifle alright good news
Alright good news we're in the circle as it stands right now
Okay,  bad news? I still have
Consumption. Yeah sure let's go with that one. Yeah
That's a good one. I'm gonna give you a 30 to 40 years. Oh come on, dude
What? The teammate I just open a chest the teammate right over here was like oh a gun
I thank you I'll take that. Dickhole. I know that life whoa we're 29 to 40. Oh my god. What happened?
Somebody got boooned geez our team is everyone sucking the big dick, huh?
Yeah, why do we keep getting these teams that get their ass kicked?
I'm gonna go to the top of the hill on the south side and see if I can perch up
I got a sniper, so I'm gonna see if I can do some damage with it. I'm gonna go over with mark
Just like yeah, I feel like we should probably stick together. I'm not gonna go too far so I'm just gonna
I'm gonna be peeking so that I can kind of get an idea of the lay of the land
I don't see much of anything going on here all the fighting must have taken place somewhere else all tomatoe towns real close is there anything going on that way
Not that I can see from my advantage tomato town looks horrifying in low res
did anybody search this building on the outskirts of town down here to the east
I don't know probably seen a whole lot of nobody...
I don't know how much detail I can see from this distance though so.
There's an assault rifle down here if anyone needs an assault rifle. I'm good for now
There's a shotgun. I just swapped out mine for a green one there's a chest nobody opened down here Wooow
There was everything in that place. Give me the shotgun ammo
Go good. There was a door right there *Mark giggle*
Whatever, I like of the way you think surprised nobody opened that oh you guys are moving yeah we're moving around a little
Cuz there's just nothing here gooo team
I don't know where they're fighting are they coming over from Pleasant Park or something cuz that would make sense if that's where they all
Like landed cuz the bus didn't cover in that direction
yeah, whoo gunshots I
Think that was our ally knocking someone down
Whoa I see a guy I see boom! got him
Go got japaneseweirdo are more two more to the right two more to the right where how far building? I'm coming in I?
Got a couple hit. I'm gonna start building stairs there on those stairs. You see Adam got him got him gotten both
There's another guy that jumped off the the thing further back like toward the water
Well shots a yes shots from luck got it god. I took a hit, but it's alright
I'm gonna I'm gonna build up some stairs right here knocked one down
There's one like -more building over to the Northwest Northwest okay. I'm not seeing it
Well shot coming in whoa behind me behind me behind me behind you behind you Bob (;-;)
oh
God damn it. What the fuck Wade if you can cycle back on us Wade?
Damn it. How did he get both of us?
I don't know
Get him wade
Shoot him wade good job. There's another one I think
That that to your left to your left to your left to your left
oh theres a bunch Yeah, yeah throw those throw those nades
You're gonna
Got scissored it's fine crimony. There's a lot of them. yeah deathsquad?
You suck you suck dude with the shotgun you missed me three times
*Mark laugh*
don't you feel bad about it
Not report player god dammit just next teammate for God's sakes we're gonna get a win
I know we can get it a win all right where we going? we go to retail Road or Pleasant oh
Yeah, we can do retail. Yeah, lets do retail
I'm jumping early because I feel like it (Sassy)
Oh god. I pressed f again
stupid hue I am
We know I have I have a friend SuperDuper close to me right now is it me oh is it a friend? no no is it a friend is it?
Might be me
Are you close to me right now? Yeah? I'm very close. I'm a little in front of you, too
That's that's not that's oh no wait that's not me. No. That's me I
whatever its fine what is it
I don't know. I don't know I see the guy you're talking about. It's not you all right
I'm gonna try to we've got friends down here. I'm going for the supermarket in the back back left
Yeah, okay. I'll come that way. I'm going for the house next
here by the basketball court I have a
revolver
Okay, guys submachine gun got a potion man. I'm finding all the potions great. I've got two revolvers
All right, I've got an ally on the ground near me I found bandages, okay
I didn't get a chest, but I got a lot
of ammo a lot ammo a legendary consumable is that the slime thing oh look a bush
oh Yeah, do that. Oh definitely do that
Oh hello. Oh you had a bush Yeti. I'm a bush dude.That's sick does this last forever
Uh, yeah, it's like a it's like a permanent thing. I think you can turn it up
I think when you crouch you become a bush, right
is that how that works? yes, I don't know I don't know it's something like that wade. I don't know all right
I'm moving to the houses nearby yeah, I got guns seems like no enemy presence as far as I can tell
Very little okay, there's definitely woo yes, please
there's a chest in this building
I hear it. I'm gonna try and steal your chest please do
pushing up this hill a little bit um to see if theres stuff in these little buildings before we get our allies looting everything all right cool
So do I actually even look like a real bush or  Is this just like some stupid things good. No no you honestly
Do like you become invisible when you have that shit. Yeah, if you stand still you are no different than any other bush
I've never actually seen one of those in person where you at, oh, you're kind of far away
I'd like to see that I got a bush you oh you got a bush too?
you both got bushes? wheres my bush?!
fuck Baby don't fuck, baby that's join the bush clan
I'm gonna just say right out, and that's a no no no
mark I'm near you Are you oh god, I would never be able to tell
oh my god I'm a bush
Bush a bush a bush. You know what screw you guys. Why can't I be a  bush? George w bush
Why cant I be a bush you can't be a bush because you're not cool enough, okay?
You know I was thinking that you didn't need to say out loud, okay you know?
my bush is moving you wanna be bushes next to each other? ugh you guys suck
why can't I be a bush?! Somebody rubbed some dirt on my eyes Mark get between us
we will protect you yeah no one will know Sweet bush all right
Where are we moving to you know what I think you have to do wade every time you crouch and become invisible
What?
BUSH every time every time your your becoming oh
Shit what was that whats happening why are there explosions I?
Have no idea okay. Honestly. The bush is a little obnoxious when you're trying to like see stuff whoa
That was nearby who the hell. I think oh
There's a grenades being thrown due East due east yeah our teammate threw those
But who's shooting on I don't understand. What's happening. He's like shooting at you me wait who Wade?
maybe you just saw a bush and was like whoa bush a
Walking bush what the fuck? what how? they're just wasting their ammo
okay we've got the collective here I've got a bandages, but that's about it
we're two people running up a hill looking like bushes some people are probably just like dumbasses bush bush bush bush bush bush
Wish I was a bush guys bush wait when you're crouched and you move its obvious its not that obvious
Oh someone's dancing okay? Why this is why our team loses guys not the bushes and those guys guys look guys look look I'm a bush
Boosh everyone's getting in the bushes. Oh you see someone I don't know
this asshole is just like constantly shooting i guess he's never played a video game where you get a weapon before wow this is dangerous
everyone watch out
guys I got a gun I got a gun guys losers I just that's irresponsible bushwhack that rock Wow
Wow would you could you not?
What this fucking guy who's just shooting? That's that guy? just just shooting at
Nothing I'm gonna come along with you friends
has anybody gone down here yet?
Honestly, I don't know I would thought there would have been more enemies, but don't go in there alone. Just yet
I've got a teammate down here. Yeah, but wait up for us
I don't I don't feel safe letting anyone go on their own. Even if it's like twos
Sorry, I just worry. I worry wait. Oh, you're good. You're good dad
I understand I see stairs built outside of it, so it's probably been looted. Oh
Insect too. Just gonna. Let me call you dead who'd you call that it's a great pistol up you?
Know I'm good on weapons. I'm just for a mo
You were like I worry, and I was like dead I understand
Like yeah, yeah, I see nothing no things I see nothing my eyes. Just suddenly stopped working all right
All right, well. I don't know where they are, but we wait wait we the circle is on us
Let's go back meet up with those guys who were on the hill because if we all camp out there
That's a good hill because the circle is also a little bit less obvious
Yeah, well yeah
Southwest of us no I didn't those are different guys. That's a different group
I think so I think the main brunt of our group is actually still by that hill till we should like I
See people jumping north of us. I think that might be a bad guy north of us building directly north behind behind, okay
All right, I'm gonna flank around this right side of the hill here
Yeah, they're building. There's definitely our teammates there, so should we build or should we try to sneak this?
I only saw one guy there soon. They saw me. They saw okay, go around the right side of the the hill
I'm flanking up. I'm just a bush. I'm just a bush where the
Bush okay from that building. Yeah wouldn't complex that they were concerned. I try to flank I can come
For a second, I think he definitely probably saw me, I'm just to push building stairs ignore me
Ignore the push stairs missed him. I am a terrible shot apparently
Out to the left running away building more yeah
Got him or hit him I gotta hit on him - he's running very quickly
Okay, I'm not gonna waste am on he moved down to the left into that compound yeah
Hey nice, bush man. No. It's broken tree. I'm a bush
Hey, do I look inconspicuous here? Yes, extremely weight that the depot is heavily fortified I?
Don't like that. I'm gonna
There's people all around there
I'm gonna start building up wave teammates pushing up toward us this appears to be the location of the final showdown for I know some
about final showdowns, this is a
predominantly it
And guys I'm gonna build some low walls, I'm just a bush hitting a tree with the pickaxe
Don't worry about me all right building some don't worry go over it go over it man. Dude. Go over it over it
Dude, stuck go over it you stupid shit
God dammit you guys suck. I'm just
Shots behind oh god
It's the guy again being an idiot just shooting up in the air for no reason how do I add a window?
Hit G edit it put a hole in the middle of it. Why did they just throw a smoke grenade at me?
someone got shot
I'm not sure from her. Oh, they're all over that roof. There are guys shooting for more like Northwest - yeah
He looks stupid you don't come on man. You look great. Okay? I'm gonna try to move
Oh
Shit
Try to get this guy up come on come on
Yeah, that's all I see
Farther and farther in okay. I'll get him up you build around
No stop moving oh god. I'm like out of materials to build with already knocked one out oh
Come on, don't
Why oh, I just took away the shield of one of these guys oh shit, they're attacking my stairs oh
God there's one on the right, I just
We've got a lot of incoming
No shit snacks
God get out of my way wait you oh, you're so far up. Okay wait. I'm gonna try that
Down in the open like that there. I was running down here try to get ammo
There's also a Gold sniper, but I would have been fired this idiot has done for me, okay
No way
Oh stupid wait, I'm gonna try to build walls in front of you. Okay, just keep backing up
Just keep backing up. Okay. All right here. We go. I will try. I will try to help cover this
This is the wrong way. Oh my god
I got the wrong wall huh, I'm bailing I'm bailing I forget I had the wrong wall queued up
Let me try and I feel safer down here than I do back way up come forward
I'm coming around
Okay, I'm gonna build the tunnel walls
Why my god why is it Oh the construction materials, not enough Jesus? I'm very low on materials distracting them
I'm gonna try and stick this on stick this revive on Wade
Okay, I think we're have enough building up to throw them off. Yeah
Are you should be good?
Yeah, you got any less weight. I got heels if you bring them back to this the the stairs area
We need to like move up though no we're doing good. We're picking them off. We're actually at a surplus right now
I'm gonna go. I'm gonna go harvest trees get more supplies. Oh god that wall is gonna
Yes, I did teammate tried to get it take the credit for my word
I'm trying to get materials so that I can actually build up. Yeah, I'm like out of materials
Is there wait wait wait Circle Circle Circle? You're in the circle wait wait wait?
Wait take these bandages
All right Wade crawl back to me crawl back to me you see where I am
Yeah, I got you stupid circle. Yeah, we got the disadvantage, but it's right on them
Yeah, but it's okay because I think I think we're gonna. We've got the number advantage right now. Where are these bandages. I'm gonna
I've got when I drop them right here okay with our friends. It's 2112, but they're pushing into that fortification gotcha
Okay, I'm moving up. We've got guys in the fortification there
Yeah, we're pushing up
There's one on the ground in this red building that I'm running towards right yeah like all the way all the way down
Gaucho bitch hitting I hit something in there
It's 3:00 we're gonna win this
yeah, I
See it I see a lotta left. There's rocket launcher shoot him shoot you shoot, bub. Where's the one?
Yeah, I'm officially out of ammo if you go to the right. There's a guy that I killed yeah. I'll go around to the right
Whoa
damn
Where are these motherfuckers are they not a part of this? I'm behind enemy lines right now, but there's only one left oh
He's in here with me. Okay. I only got he's a bush. He's a bush where you our final enemies a bush guys
I've got a rocket launcher. I'm coming Kay. He's wrapped right around this corner. He's right there. Oh
He's upstairs with me oh he's in the corner hi, I don't know it is
stupid
Which way we're behind you right behind you that Bush in the corner. It's UV that bush get him
There you go, that was good
Good one I know right, it's fun when you win and live